alors nous allons sur la pelouse du
jardin de l'élysée retrouver leur knicks
insolite du nouveau du côté des
tricolores véronique et bien oui vous
pouvez l'entendre la cei est depuis
quelques secondes la chanson we have
championnat a démarré alors vous je ne
sais pas si vous les voyez mais les gens
chantent dans se tiennent par les bras
et les tricolores les bleus sont là les
héros du jour sont là sur le perron avec
le président de la république qui vient
les rejoindre vous entendez j'imagine
oui mais on aurait beaucoup de joie et
d'allégresse la musique la musique très
très fort et plus tous ces
applaudissements qui éclatent et les
voilà envoyé le président de la
république qui arrive sur le perron
il est entouré donc par les footballeurs
qui le rejoint une pique à pied
l'ambiance est très détendue tout le
monde sur la pelouse applaudi les jeunes
employés sur les épaules les uns des
autres pour essayer d'apercevoir la fête
on a du mal à imaginer qu'on est à
l'elysée quand on voit la balle y est
plus leur à ça il faut reconnaître que
c'est pas une ambiance très fréquentes
ici mais ça y est vous ayez la halle à
ckoi tillion gagne la coupe du monde non
plus la beauty mandela le président de
la république est extrêmement détendu la
musique au plus bas
je vous laisse écouter l'ambiance parce
qu'elle parle d'elle-même on dira tout
le monde est uni d'abandonner les petits
fours et le champagne
voyez les bras qui s'agite le premier
ministre a rejoint le président la
république
voilà tout le monde chante maintenant
le monde change le plus quand la
république le premier
freddie mercury du groupe queen qui a
marqué cette coupe du monde
quatre-vingt dix-huit mois et s'est fait
pression pendant tant que ça dans la
cour de l'elysée leur dans le jardin de
l'univers
alors que la nageuse de laurent blanc
ont aussi entité la bise
avec tout le staff technique nous a
rason entre le bâti
magnifique défenseur qui a remplacé
laurent blanc qui l'a localisé et je
crois que le président de la république
s'apprête à prendre la parole
nous allons les couper
bien une seule honte j'ai une seconde
une seconde je voudrais je voudrais
saluer au nom du gouvernement
en mon nom et au nom de toute l'équipe
de france
tous les jeunes les 4000 jeunes qui
viennent de la france entière
ils viennent de la france entière de
métropole des départements et des
territoires d'outre-mer et je leur fais
un cadeau le plus beau cadeau qu'ils
puissent rêver l'équipe de france
vingt équipes de france et la coupe de
pan
la cote du moment un croc du monde et en
votre nom à tous je voudrais leur dire
notre admiration
notre reconnaissance et notre amitié
ils sont la plus belle image que vous
garderez de la france de cette année
dans votre coeur et je vais demander
balle temps à celles qui ne sont pas
pour peu dans cette victoire
c'est à dire à leurs épouses de bien
vouloir nous rejoindre
maintenant vers ces dames de venir
et c'est vrai qu'on les a acquis les a
vus tout au long de ce mondial ces
femmes qui étaient dans les tribunes
pour soutenir leurs époux qu'elles n'ont
pas vu beaucoup pendant les deux mois de
préparation va ici les les bout'choux
qui sont avec elle et qui seront donc
sur la photo publiée le 14 juillet 98
assez exceptionnel à tous conneries
merci pour ce que vous avez fait il nous
revient une part importante de cette
victoire
voilà alors tout ça est très peu
protocolaire véronique ça ça ne
ressemble pas trop photos de
gouvernement qu'on voit d'habitude c'est
du jamais vu ça à l'elysée on n'avait
jamais vu une foule aussi dense des
jeunes aussi enthousiaste et politique
mise à part il faut bien le dire comme
unis dans une même ferveur pour leurs
sportifs et jacques chirac n'est pas
durable et n'est pas en reste vous voyez
une lève le bras
il sourit il acclame ils adorent
organiser les photos de famille ça vous
allez voir il va donc le faire lui-même
mais légion en place l'équipe de france
est très fier d'avoir remporté cette
coupe du monde
elle est très fière de voir toute la
population française heureuse et nous
sommes tellement fiers d'avoir réussi
notre pari quand vous le town cette
double on vous appartient
voilà aimé jacquet à qui la france vous
attend et qui reçoit aujourd'hui un
hommage mérité à l'elysée en ce jour de
fête nationale
voilà didier deschamps capitaine excusez
moi j'ai un peu la voix que les diminuer
je voudrais en temps de trouver les
joueurs vous remercier de tout votre
soutien durant cette coupe du monde et
c'est vrai comme l'a dit aimé jacquet on
est championne du monde mais vous aussi
et toute la france est championne du
monde merci voilà les mots du capitaine
qui a dû lui aussi se coucher tard la
république qui a risqué a essayé
d'imposer le silence pour qu'on
l'entendra mais c'est ça bien alors là
c'est quoi sinon aulas qui démarre alors
là c'est encore une alarme et vous voyez
tout autour des applaudissements les
je me sens fort heureux ils ont envie de
montrer le faire savoir il fait
quasiment des bronziers c'est la leur on
qui vous disais aux communes et dans un
même enthousiasme message est pas
politique mais il s'agit vraiment de
ferveur nationale autour de ces
footballeurs qui pour gare d'hirson les
héros du jour
combien y at-il de personnes véronique
estimations jacques chirac lui-même a
annoncé de 4000 jeunes alors ses 4000
jeunes sont venus de toute la france et
même des pays francophones
ils ont été choisis pour l'heure leur
intérêt pour le foot voyelles présent la
république s'être emparé à son tour de
la coupe du monde il a bondi à me
l'avait promis qu'ils sont prêts pour la
remettre et de ce point de vue là il
tempéré
l'âge moyen d'un partage avec team usa
green jacket
nico alors le président demande de micro
il a encore un petit mot ajouté
peut-être on reste avec vous à ces
images sont magnifiques c'est un moment
exceptionnel que nous vivons ensemble
les images elles sont uniques et elles
sont exceptionnelles
allez un p'tit coup de queen encore
freddie mercury
oui
zinédine zidane
le héros de la finale
et parce que moi je parle pas ford et
jade alors je voulais tester simplement
dire que vous remercier de votre soutien
qui fait tout le soutien que vous avez
porté pour tati tout cette coupe du
monde et maintenant elle est là au moins
pour quatre ans donc on va la garder et
on va faire encore la fête très
longtemps mais merci merci à tout le
monde
voilà ils n'ont pas l'air de vouloir
arrêter de faire la fête c'est positif
ça n'a pas l'air de vouloir quitter
l'elysée du tout on vous l'a dit vouloir
y passer toute leur après-midi lors les
buffets sont bien garnis le jus d'orange
et champagne coule à flots les petits
fours aussi il faut bien reconnaître que
pour l'instant ça me saoule ne sont pas
les buffets qui intéresse on va tirer
les leçons là hein on a cru marquer que
les petits fours c'est un flop en ce
moment oui non là tout le monde et tout
le monde a les yeux tournés vers
l'estrade où les vers l'estrade vert les
marches vers le perron de l'elysée où
jacques chirac est entourée des
tricolores
on attend on attend un petit mode là un
petit mot de l'autre pour l'instant
personne ne bouge elle a fait est
toujours là
j'imagine que les photographes ont
immortalisé l'événement avec eux et
qu'on retrouvera sa dent dans tous les
journaux et on va peut-être les garder
parce que c'est vraiment dommage aussi
c'est tout à fait faux bond voilà
président de la république qui partage
la vedette avec avec tous les champions
les champions du monde comme aimé
jacquet vous voyez mes jacques est à
côté du président de la république il
essaye et 2
le passé quelques marches mais
à la marque visiblement marie george
buffet une solution on reconnaît tout
cela se fait dans une atmosphère
extraordinairement bon enfant il ya pas
du tout protocole le service de sécurité
et réduit au minimum
on a le sentiment que tout le monde est
heureux d'être là et qu aucune fausse
note le peu de panache et là
et on a vu marie george buffet qui a qui
a assisté à un bon nombre des matches de
cette coupe du monde et à tous ceux des
tricolores elle était comme de nombreux
mondes du gouvernement au stade de
france dimanche soir pour applaudir à
cette victoire incroyable passe face au
brésil alors là visiblement se déplacent
peut-être vers les buffets cette fois ci
est temps de manger 14h karakama sa
personne entouré par y est entouré par
les joueurs ou ceux qui ceux qui
appelait la suite parce que et amour
d'absolument incroyable et il se dit
venus vers vers la pousse de l'elysée
pense qu'il aurait sa pelouse et qui est
bordé donc des deux côtés par des par
ces fameux but peine encore parlé tout à
l'heure alors une autre musique un
concours tiendra ça aussi on les écoute
ensemble véronique allait justement je
parlais de la musique qui repart la ccc
l'un des hymnes de cette coupe du monde
pour l'essence et de cadre à la musique
joue peinture alors les hyènes fera dans
l'eure
agite des drapeaux ceux qui le peuvent
et c'est de toucher d'approché président
de la république ou là où l'un des
footballeurs tous les membres du
gouvernement sont là bien sûr pour moi
beaucoup aussi d'hommes politiques
d'opposition on a vu philippe séguin qui
est un passionné de foot quand marie
george buffet lundi qui suit président
de la république
les seuls qui essayent la chambre facho
et pas seulement pour pour madame buffet
est un choc pour tout le monde
oui j'ai l'impression que le service
d'ordre un peu du mal à fermer
j'ai l'impression que c'est nous sommes
abandonnés oui on voit ou carrément
abandonné on ne violera quelleenergie
dans la foule au milieu de tous ces
jeunes on a vu à képi partir un peu de
travers à palerme est content que ça se
passe comme ça
voilà robert pires qui signent des
autographes
peut-être au monde de la garde
républicaine dans ses pas lui mais il en
demandera peut-être plus tard
mais c'est à croire cette présidence a
dit me reste du monde tout le monde nous
fait la bise aurait tout à y partager
cette émotion la tradition à l'ats
christian karembeu
avec arlette qui demande un autographe
peut-être oui mais oui elle est
après ça sera comme une demande de nous
le montrer un voile à arlette chabot
tout blanc dans notre data axis tian
carembault
au mieux c'est
demandons
mais a disparu dans la foule
soit plus on va pas être très loin
les dj dan qui
aussi si vous
ah ça vaut cher qu'à deux buts en finale
de la coupe du monde de très grave des
zidane c'est collector
j'ai l'impression qu'il il s'en va
chloé djorkaeff
philippe séguin grand amateur de foot
les faits hier sur les champs elysées
pour saluer le passage du bus
impérial
devant ce avait pris place avec la coupe
du monde il était là philippe séguin on
l'a vu à que dire
triomphe des français aimé jacquet que
reconnaît vaguement au loin à gauche on
s'est vus on avancera
alors vu la mêlée j'ai l'impression que
c'est plus du football et c'est du rugby
là alors absolument il y a également
aujourd'hui à l'elysée les deux les deux
équipes de rugby les deux équipes
finalistes de rugby l'équipe de
perpignan et l'équipe du stade français
et puis à d'autres footballeurs mais
alors il ya deux autres équipes de
footballeurs l'équipe de lens qui a
gagné la coupe france et l'équipe du psg
qui est donc champion de france
vraiment que ce soit contraire véronique
à ça peut-être c'est le psg qui a gagné
la coupe de france et lens qui a éveillé
les championnes et champions de france
c'est gentil alors ce matin on nous
avait dit vous savez on ne sait pas très
bien comment ça va se passer ça dépend
le président souhaite s'adapter à la
situation va on voit on voit qu'ils
s'adaptent il prend son temps il va
serrer des mains et il avance tout
doucement des gens autour de lui
continuent de se bousculer pour
l'apercevoir de l'apercevoir aussi les
plus beaux leur silence on était bien le
dire
voilà aimé jacquet qui est sur les
talons de jacques chirac
on ne les prend au l'idée de la foule
c'était annonce
ces images sont étonnantes étonnant du
président un peu chahutée de très très
fière très sympathique évidemment par la
ferveur mais vraiment dedans dans le
palais de l'elysée on doit pas voir ça
tous les jours voilà je crois même que
c'est la première fois j'ai la pression
les diables république à ne pas en venir
voilà il ay la sortie d'une mauvaise
passe je ne suis plus répandue de photos
voilà marie george buffet qui raconte sa
traversée
stéphane guivarc'h aussi les agrafes lui
aussi a participé à cette finale
et si son côté
et ils sont d'autant plus méritant je le
disais le début de ce journal ils ont
passé une soirée très longue qui en a
suivi une autre elle aussi très bien
on a l'impression qu'ils sont toujours
aussi frais et dispo en garde aimé
jacquet qui répond aux interviews de
mon frère ils sont frais et dispo mais
ils n'ont plus de voir
et encore cette musique
cette musique qui restera comme après
je suis inquiète
balmy qui voulait être qui aurait pu
être gardien de but finalement c'est un
peu comme si j'avais participé ici même
un ballon en garde et c'est formidable
signée jacques chirac
le ballon tricolore il paraît qu'on
retrouve plus dit bois il était pourtant
à 500 francs à peu près ce ballon de la
coupe du monde il paraît que tous les
magasins de sport sont en rupture de
stock on n'en trouve plus nulle part ça
s'est arraché vendus comme des petits
pains
souvenir d'une coupe du monde gagnée par
la france le monde a envie d'avoir ce
ballon et pourtant
autant de footballeurs que ça et on
recommence la musique passe est
magnifique mais il est à la barre
alors j'ai vu tout à l'heure une
négociation au trésor entre une entre
deux personnes l'une voulait d'échanger
un schéma pour deux jours de coude au 15
juillet un marché qui va faire s'ils
arrivent oh oui
voilà thierry henry qui veut signer des
autographes
titi il cotait des ulis à doigts
on va leur faire plaisir de voir la
réussite de ce joueur
si lui aussi a participé au succès des
habitudes français ils signent des
autographes et ils ont pas fini à mon
ami pendant donc vous allez encore à mon
avis on va leur en demander des
autographes
en tout cas on n'oubliera pas cette
équipée et cette succession d'imagés
extraordinaires qu'on a qu'on a vu
pendant ces 48 dernières heures depuis
le coup de sifflet final
jusqu'à aujourd'hui sont tout aussi
étonnante aussi magnifiques les unes que
les autres
on meurt nick j'imagine que maintenant
on va on va se diriger tout le monde va
essayer de se diriger vers l'est vers
les buffets pour de collationner un
petit peu je crois maintenant que l'idée
c'est de faire cette fameuse photo de
famille c'est à dire que le président de
la république regroupent autour de lui
l'équipe des bleus et qu'enfin us
immortaliser ces journées et toute cette
ferveur dans une photo historique bien
bat véronique on va on va conclure sur
ces images cette photo historique vous
la verrez sans doute dans vos quotidiens
demain matin c'est un c'est un très beau
moment que nous avons vécu ensemble un
nouveau grand moment de ferveur
populaire pour ce 14 juillet 1998 et
c'est sur ces images que nous allons
maintenant nous séparer images en direct
de l'elysée c'est la fin de cette
édition que je vous remercie d'avoir
suivi dans un instant la météo puis le
tour de france le sport continue sur
france 2 merci à tous
à demain 13h au revoir